I'm standing here with my good pal Nick
Kroll hey Nick I'm good thanks wait a
minute you don't think we're good
balance I think we're friends Nick has
created one of my favorite shows right
now big mouth
hilarious show on Netflix thank you it's
about kids going through puberty and
human sexual development so we're gonna
go inside right now
and talk to the youth of Burbank
California you're gonna go into the high
school and talk to kids about sex yes
yeah something that I've been arrested
twice for now has to do yeah so we
thought maybe would be a good idea that
we would talk to you guys a little bit
about sex education where you guys are
out so between us we've had over three
sexual partners how old are all of you
guys how old are you guys you're 15
great 18 conan has been married longer
than you've been alive
that's right perhaps you are one of
Conan's children this guy and actually
this guy right here yeah look first of
all I want to say there's the reason
that I never adopted you legally but
what's your name Connor no your knowing
it oh my god I was very late bloomer and
I got pantsed when I was a little kid
and everybody saw my bald little cashew
and it was quite serving
big penis is comparable to that of a
baby who's in sex ed right now who's in
a sex ed class you are what are you guys
learning right now in sex ed about like
the anatomy here we go I have one of
these in my kitchen at home and this is
misleading I think a lot of kids see
this and I think that sperm is that
large no a sperm is like half this size
how do you guys have you guys start
talking about like consent or anything
like that yeah yeah you should only be
having sex with someone if they're
definitely into it only have sex with
someone if they're definitely into it
yes that would kill my sex life with my
wife
we've got condoms and this is a Magnum
oh they make them this big that's right
pinch the reservoir of the condom and
this is on backwards though so what you
want to do when you have Economist's get
two men comedians to help you put it on
and then you eat it you take it off
right and then and then you close it up
right the tighter to not tie a knot and
then you mail this to your Congressman
here's a here's a healthy penis this is
not a healthy penis it's not supposed to
come back around and come at you like
that but I would I'd be like man I guess
this would be described as a chode this
is how by the way this baby look at that
there's like cocaine in here you know
this is one of the consequences of
having unprotected sex right is you get
a baby that's filled with sand this is
what my penis looks like now once you
hit 40 guys the penis forms these ridges
and then these leaves sprout at the top
and it becomes a delicious source of
pineapple juice is this like a beats
beats by dre ovaries like what is that
we were about to talk about masturbation
right how old were you when this when it
all began
oh I was probably like 14 it was a
Victoria Secrets catalog so yeah Frank
yeah what about you do you remember I
was watching I think was Richard Nixon
on TV I remember when I was a kid I just
assumed the vagina was like on the front
like like penises were do you know what
I mean I went two years I thought it was
over here like people are watching porn
though does it feel like people are
watching for you yeah yeah the imagery
is so unrealistic if they made it like
actual sex yeah we are interrupted by
your kid
and then I got cat makes a noise and you
know your partner says I gotta go feed
the cat I'll be right back and then you
get disgruntled then you start watching
TV and then you both fall asleep yeah
they should make realistic pornography
realistic pornography with middle aged
people my fake son is like I don't want
to watch dad yes where your thoughts on
flavored condoms I know nothing about
that do you know anything about flavored
condoms I mean just when I'm hungry yes
you have a question how much do you
think you really know about female and
another do you ask that question cuz
you've got the sense we don't know much
about it particularly eight-plus yeah
all right yeah you're welcome
you're welcome cuz I'm sure that you
were gonna probably applaud as we left
[Applause]
no not at all thanks to the kids to the
Cooper Bank they really they were very
sweet